hallo miguel
hallo ursula
geht es dir
gut danke
was machst du dieses wochenende
machen wir eine fahrradtour
oder gehen wir zusammen wandern
es ist schönes wetter
ich kam diese
leider nicht
ich kann diese
ich muss meine wohnung putzen und
aufräumen
es gibt viel zu tun
[Musik]
es gibt viel
zu tun
ich muss die wäsche war
ich musste
gewaschen
danach muss sich die wäsche bügeln
danach muss sich die wäsche
zusammenlegen
ich muss die fenster putzen
ich muss das bad saubermachen
ich muss die toilette putzen
ich muss den boden fliegen
ich muss den boden fegen
ich muss den boden feucht aufnehmen
[Musik]
ich muss in der wohnung staubsaugen
ich muss den rasen mähen
ich muss die pflanzen gießen
ich muss das geschirr abwaschen
ich muss den keller aufräumen
ich muss den mülleimer leeren
ich muss den müllsack rausbringen
[Musik]
ich muss mein auto waschen
ich muss
die pet-flaschen das glas und die dosen
recyceln
ich muss die pet-flaschen das glas und
die dosen recyceln
ich muss auch noch im supermarkt
einkaufen
ich muss das essen kochen
du hast aber viel zu tun die arme
du hast aber viel zu tun
du armer der die oder dass der/die oder
das wesen der besen der besen
staubsauger
der staubsauger der staubsauger
mob der mob der mob
staubfänger der staubfänger der
staubfänger schwamm der schwamm der
schwamm
der lappen der lappen reinigungsmittel
das reinigungsmittel das
reinigungsmittel
schmittel
das waschmittel das waschmittel
waschbecken das waschbecken
das waschbecken
die waschen
schiene die waschmaschine
bügeleisen das bügeleisen das bügeleisen
bügelbrett das bügelbrett das bügelbrett
wäsche die wäsche die
schön
diesen der wc wesen der wc besen
der eimer der eimer gerichtsakt müllsack
abfallsack der kehricht sack der
müllsack der abfallsack der kehricht
sack der müllsack der abfallsack
altpapier das altpapier das altpapier
die mülltonne die mülltonne die
mülltonne
papierkorb der papierkorb
der papierkorb
müllwagen der müllwagen
der müllwagen
gießkanne die gießkanne
die gießkanne
gartenschlauch der gartenschlauch
der gartenschlauch
rasenmäher der rasenmäher
der rasenmäher
sprühflasche die sprühflasche
die sprühflasche
wasser das abwasser
das abwasser
die kläranlage
akl
gerichts an
die gerichts anlage
dreck
der dreck
schmutz
der schmutz der schmutz nicht vergessen
dieses video zu liken zu kommentieren
und zu teilen hat dir das video gefallen
abonniere unseren kanal hat dir das
video gefallen abonniere unseren kanal